Emmanuel Macron veut tourner la page des
retraites
mais c'était sans compter sur plusieurs
dizaines de manifestants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça veut dire quoi usage de la force là
de les faire de les repousser
tranquillement vers le tranquillement ou
en force tranquillement pour le moment
environ 200 manifestants contre la
réforme des retraites voulaient voir le
président mais il resteront à plusieurs
centaines de mètres au milieu de cette
bousculade on a repéré 7 pancarte Manu
on t'aime mange déconne mais le
président n'était pas dans ce cortège
une contestation sociale qui existe sur
une réforme mais ça veut pas dire que
tout doit s'arrêter et c'est normal on
continue à travailler parce que il se
trouve qu'il y a toujours des problèmes
d'inflation on doit continuer à réduire
le chômage dans notre pays on doit
répondre aux problèmes de sécheresse
évidemment la vie continue évidemment le
thème de l'eau est vital comme d'autres
mais si le président de la République
croit qu'on avançant tout seul dans son
coin il va sortir du blocage politique
il se trompe complètement je pense que
Emmanuel Macron est fidèle à lui-même
finalement même quand il se déplace il
se tient loin des Français après
plusieurs tentatives de bloquer les
routes les manifestants ont finalement
été dispersés par les forces de l'ordre
parmi eux deux individus ont été
interpellés ce matin et un moment de
clarification politique qui a donné lieu
à un vote à l'Assemblée nationale après
qui est des commentaires c'est une chose
mais
ça a été clarifié au moment de du vote
sur la motion de censure il va en
Afrique il dépense des milliards pour
rien pour le métro marocain pour
l'écologie africaine il va en Ukraine il
dépense de l'argent je veux dire on peut
pas dépenser des milliards toutes les
semaines et venir dire aux Français bon
ben vous allez bosser deux ans de plus
parce que il faut économiser 15
milliards ou 17 milliards est-ce que les
74 sont discutables pas l'intention
on abandonne les 64 ans et donc je vous
réponds très directement nous à cette
conviction qu'on doit rééquilibrer et
préserver notre système de retraite et
donc qu'on a porté une réforme des
retraites avec une augmentation donc
passer l'expression ce sera à cause
toujours tu m'intéresses il y a beaucoup
de choses autour des 64 ans sur lesquels
Laurent Berger souhaite avancer sur
lesquels le gouvernement souhaite
avancer sur l'usure professionnelle sur
le cumul emploi retrait sur les
retraites progressives parce
qu'imaginons un sommaire sans que le
Président de la République fasse ce que
vous dites qui le suspendent ou qui le
retire la réforme ce qui revient à peu
près la même chose à quelques subtilités
près qu'est-ce qu'on dira on dira qu'on
est incapable en France de faire des
réformes importantes les mêmes qui
aujourd'hui disent de présents de la
République à trop d'autorité diront il
est trop beau la question des 64 ans
vous ne reviendrez pas dessus mais je
vais pas redire la même chose tous les
quatre jours
sinon on bégaye dernière information sur
l'état de santé du pape François il
souffre d'une infection respiratoire il
est hospitalisé depuis hier et va le
rester plusieurs jours avant je parlais
d'arbitrage maintenant le mot qui vient
c'est restrictions on a une partie
grandissante des Français qui se
restreint sur ses achats et
particulièrement l'alimentaire pour
continuer augmentation inquiétante des
passages aux urgences en lien avec la
consommation de cocaïne ils ont été
multipliés par trois en 12 ans Paris
s'inquiète après l'arrestation d'un
journaliste américain en Russie la
France s'appelle Moscou à respecter la
liberté de la presse il aurait été
arrêté pour espionnage de son côté le
Kremlin mettant garde Washington contre
toute forme de représailles progrès de
l'intelligence artificielle et ferait
même les experts ils sont plus de 1300 à
avoir signé une pétition réclamant une
pause dans le développement de logiciels
comme le robot conversationnel chat GPT
parmi eux Elon Musk et co-fondateur
d'Apple qui sont les joueurs les mieux
payés du champion d’atte France pas
vraiment de surprises regardez le trio
de tête il est parisien numéro un Kylian
Mbappé qui touche 6 millions d'euros
brut par mois suivi de Neymar 3,6
millions et Messi 3,3 millions ils
appellent un moratoire de 6 mois le
temps de mettre en place des systèmes de
sécurité et de surveillance plus
puissants qui permettrait de distinguer
le réel de l'artificiel et de se
préparer à des perturbations économiques
et politiques le texte évoque des
risques majeurs pour l'humanité